[Musik]
es ist als wäre mir in ein schwarzes
loch und alles wo je zu mir gehört hat
ich werde einfach die dinge zu und
verschwindet in der dunkelheit das und
jetzt gehen sie zu wollen und
was sicher gravierenden punkt ist dass
wir eigentlich
vorstand rolf müller schaffte und
nicht zwischen zwei stunden
sport ist allgegenwärtig
die gängige deutung es geht um eine
überlastung im beruf die zum
zusammenbruch wird aber so einfach ist
es nicht
denn
irgendwo
[Musik]
bernard ist vielmehr als stress allein
das leiden der betroffenen ist groß
wenn das ist
existenzängste als ich angst sie vor dem
absturz aller fälle ganz kommt sturz im
slalom ankara
drei menschen mit burnout drei völlig
unterschiedliche geschichte eine
langzeitbeobachtung die fortuna den
anfang nahm
[Musik]
das ist verrückt aber gesetzes mini
burnoutprävention
pcs meditativ schön und schlussendlich
haider hier schöne
verstaut mitredet sicherer quelle
zuletzt erklärte fertig machen die
arbeit eigentlich im vor ihm im
abschluss stress sie im
geschäftsabschluss stress
mittag das wäre fertig machen und flink
flinker
jetzt plötzlich haus abbrennen und so
ist das ganze jahr fand
[Musik]
kaum zu glauben
trotz schweren verletzungen setzt sie
sich an den computer und arbeitet weiter
dass das nicht ganz so trivial ist
es sowas mit genauer vertreter von der
woche und hat die ganze nacht
bis zum glück
und geschick kann ich somit waschplatz
mikrooptik sehe jetzt mich für die linke
geht ist ja völlig sie und dani
entschieden dass ich das ignorieren für
das sie da jahresabschluss bewusst
leistungsbereitschaft
und neu aushandeln
ja und jetzt einfach gut gemacht wähle
das irgend ein bisschen geschafft muss
liter man werde jetzt mit beton von
karmann
[Musik]
am späten nachmittag wird doris brülhart
ins unispital zürich gebracht
zweieinhalb wochen wird sie dort
behandelt
zu hause in der heilungsphase folgt der
nächste schlag
ganz komische gericht patron die macher
und vorwürfe mir dass sie so kauth
unterschlagen hat
und da bin ich doch das glück ist mir
völlig aus der supercup eine ganz
schlimme überhaupt vertretbar
riesige angst habe was ich da
was die ständig mehr da und was ist da
ist ja das ist übrig sie das ganze
im innenstadt auf
diese bilder hat doris brülhart während
der produktion eines werbespots gedreht
den sie auf dem höhepunkt ihrer karriere
produzieren will sie arbeitete für ein
internationales unternehmen im
gesundheitsbereich
er aufwendige spot wurde zum ursprung
des verdachts sei geld verschwunden
[Musik]
eine revision entlastete doris buhl hat
sie blieb geschäftsführerin fühlte sich
aber kontrolliert und zutiefst
verunsichert
sie haut so ganz diffuse angst sie
schlussendlich ist mini existenz gange
und
natürlich vom mini reputation und und
die
dahlemer und lacht und da nicht mehr
verantwortlich für die
existenz der familie
[Musik]
doris brülhart machte weiter
funktioniert mit hilfe von medikamenten
so gut es ging ein kampf auf verlorenem
posten
[Musik]
ich habe zum schluss die situation
und die agilität klinik
doris brühl hat wurde krankgeschrieben
später folgt die kündigung ihre diagnose
angststörung denn medizinisch gilt
bernard nicht als eigenständige
krankheit sondern nur als symptom von
psychischen beschwerden
die zahl der absenzen aus psychischen
gründen steigt in der schweiz dramatisch
an um 58 prozent in den letzten zehn
jahren
[Musik]
also mir an barca umstrukturierungen und
titania
krise verantwortliche position kann
und das ganze ist mit sehr viel stress
verbunden sie
bis muss ehrlich sagen wir mekka für und
flammenwerfer da hat es auch sehr gern
gemacht aber die umstrukturierung hand
einfach so viel kraft braucht das stetig
sie wo ich habe private und
das ist ein bisschen megaschön spa pc
aber
anstrengend gerade mir steht und
sony gar kein momente mega wohl auch
eine rolle 13 und die latente aggression
von da überhand nehme
und
egomanisch das ganze zum höhepunkt
plötzlich ist der stand woche und der
ganze stress wo sich angesammelt hat ich
auf einmal
wo das verriet sie ich
bin
komplett zusammengebrochen
meine damalige frau ist mit dem kind zu
einer freundin gegangen
das team um 17 gedankt habe
ich brauch jetzt hilfe
ein freund fährt ihn in die klinik
josef bekommt medikamente
entscheidet sich aber gegen einen
stationären aufenthalt
ein paar wochen versucht er noch weiter
zu unterrichten dann kündigt er ohne
dass der arbeitgeber von seinem burnout
erfährt
fast drei viertel jahre liegt der
zusammenbruch zurück manchmal rafft sich
josef auf musik zu machen
[Musik]
oft aber verschläft er den tag
seit monaten lastet eine schwere
depression auf ihn
[Musik]
noch am gleichen tag macht er sich auf
den weg um wieder in der psychiatrie
hilfe zu suchen
nennen wir ihn daniel
46 er ist auf stellensuche will deshalb
anonym bleiben sein burnout zeigt sich
nach einer happigen kritik des chefs
usa gefragt zum beispiel gestreckte
mittelfinger zeigt was eigentlich nicht
möglich ist weil ich mochte selbst
bemerkt die frau weg so etwas nicht gibt
persönlichen angriff mehr wo man sich
gar nicht
unfreundlich oder unflätiges zeit um und
hacker mini mini nachlässig was ich
einfach konzerns sei
also es ist so dass ich relativ
deutliche ausdrucks wie ist also durch
und schon mal drin vor wo natürlich die
zarin unbedingt die sande und
vorstellung ganz klar gesagt dass ich
sehr direkt kommuniziert ich sehe das
als stärke und euro also schwächen und
das haben sie das der begierde ist wenn
ich damals auch gesetzt und
momentan bin ich nach stadtlohn mit auch
im wörthersee aber ich bitte alle drei
aspekte wenn weiß war das betrifft sich
der coach schuldig nein das geht nicht
das ist mir bewusst
daniel uhr leitet als metallarbeiter ein
kleines team
nach einer ohren operation fühlt er sich
gesundheitlich angeschlagen und
überfordert
die vorwürfe des chefs setzen ihm extrem
zu
am
morgen um 1 woche noch richtungslos und
eine weile müssen zimmer mit dem ich
frage mich dann aber doch ab du bist
total verbringen den größten
das hat mich schon belastet
ich habe jetzt ein brief
nicht mehr zahlt nämlich allein unter
und 1000 starts bei mir so
schwester hätten die wirte darüber redet
für mensch das thema eigentlich jetzt
abgeschlossen und es fehlt noch immer
wieder auf weil die trüben gedanken
nur nach ihm meine zustand ist
geschaffen wo nicht nachher ganz morgen
so gemacht oder sich in überhaupt roßlau
also das hätten sie so beschäftigt als
ich zuerst einmal seinen älteren leute
hat zumal mit dem reden wenn er habe ich
danke jetzt muss ich handeln also wenn
da jetzt passiert ich hatte mir das nie
verzeihen
denn
aus der schusslinie ist egal was kommt
will das bringt es irgendwie geschafft
einer quiche oder anderen fall barschel
das durch
irgendein bis australien krieg
[Musik]
seine partnerin begleitet daniel uhr zum
hausarzt er wird krank geschrieben und
besucht einen psychiater
und den damit spreche ich sei nicht
moderat ihre
psyche und dafür mehr hat nicht
funktioniert
wie möglich das ist schwer zu springen
die punkte eigentlich absolut wichtiger
obwohl daniel uhr nach einer kurzen
absenz wieder zur arbeit geht wird ihm
gekündigt jetzt braucht der praktische
hilfe bei der rückkehr in den
arbeitsmarkt
genau das bietet work matt in liestal
eine fachstelle spezialisiert auf
psychische probleme in der arbeitswelt
therapiestunde mit barbara erbe
[Musik]
sollten
sondern krank ich weiß nicht das
richtige struktur sprecher
ich habe jetzt ein aufsteiger wie hat
max und von ihren autos von denen und
wurde mir leid also
wie viel mir zwar irgendwie also
eigentlich immer wieder dieser situation
wo die krankheit wurde merkel oder
ungerecht behandelt fühlen oder den hund
die reaktion
wurde schon auf 100 gehört oder high
profile sache sagt wurde im nachhinein
nicht hatte
genau das mittelmaß und kraft behandle
das ist so ein punkt wo dabei hat
begleitet wie eine verschiedene salate
scheibe eine verfügt was ich da oben
sagt nicht einmal wurde ich nicht mag
luis martinez autohersteller als
randerscheinung
und das trotz sofort sind wahnsinnig
lustig findet die man selber vorstellen
aber ich sehe das nicht so machen weil
adolf jahres lernen wie heute
wenn ich das
[Gelächter]
letzte mal
probiert mit dem 10
und zwar in allen für euch mal vor allem
auf zeit
und am schluss danke fürs gespräch oder
danke für das kommt
also ich gebe mir geschaffen werden
rock mad ist eine außenstelle der
psychiatrie baselland ihr leiter niklas
bär gilt als pionier der
arbeitspsychologie
da schwerlich hilfe bieten und
vermitteln zwischen betroffenen und
ihren arbeitgebern
der begriff burnout ist ihm zu schwammig
er hat mir nicht gut behandelt unsere
sympathisch dass ich ab und an aber wenn
wir die situationen genau wo liegt denn
ist es praktisch hier einfach nur das
wenn wir jetzt im moment wird level
karten wird mir bei jedem fünften
mitarbeiter
innerschweizer unternehmer könnte man
eine psychische kranke diagnostizieren
das heißt die allermeisten lied mit
psychische kranke problematik sind
schaffen und für viel geld
und was ist soll bis häufig
dass man irgendwann andere zugegangen
ist die filme zum thema und nicht
einfach geöffnet das ist es ist nicht
logisch wenn jeder fünfte nordsee
reduzierte er seine problematik hat
entscheidend ist wie ein foto mit
doris brühl hat kämpft sich zurück
[Musik]
dürfen ganz für beendet
nach der summe die aus dem garten zu
buche
mit selbst produzierten naturkosmetik
produkten will sie sich selbständig
machen
trägt man
ja sie ihr untergang unterbrochen
oktober das ist dass das ist nicht
aber
nein ich
glaube
ich habe mich fantastisch
fantastisch für
verkehrsberuhigung und
beruhige dich
liebe gestehen will
sich entspannen finde
es sehr befremdlich
ist ruhe eingekehrt in der familie doris
brühl hat ehemann hat ein eigenes
unternehmen gegründet und unterstützt
sie dann eben beim aufbau ihres
geschäfts der zusammenbruch ist
vergangenheit
diese krise war sozusagen von außen
barriere an getriggert
etwas in ihr bedient was offensichtlich
schon angelegt war und sozusagen dann
zum vorschein gekommen ist
pflichtbewusst und wenn mama ob eine
bestimmte aufgabe dieses jahr fühle und
ich glaube sie macht sich dann auch und
ziemliche druck zum dir auch einen
erfülle und man ist eindruck großer ok
ja aber ich mache sehr gern und nachher
gibt es der druck wo verursacher und
druck nur mit ihrem zimmer und dann ist
das einfach zu viel und dann bricht sie
zusammen ich denke das funktioniert
wahrscheinlich bei ganz vielen menschen
dass man muss nur die richtigen
schrauben drehen
und dann druck aufsetzen und dann
brechen viele einwohner die frage ist
eher warum wird das überhaupt gemacht
im keller sind die gefäße für das
kerzenziehen einem labor gerichten doris
brülhart setzt auf die selbstständigkeit
ein wagnis dass sie entspannt angeht
hier testet sie an produkten für das
sortiment ihrer neuen firma
von shampoo über körpercreme bis zu
dieser fußball
[Musik]
als ich
sie erschaffen
aber die
ghs bei umsetzung schlussresultat in die
viel mehr als fleischlich mit
kosmetischen produkten hast du mir
wahnsinnig gut
[Musik]
josef hat die behandlung in der
tagesklinik beendet er ist aber noch
weit entfernt von einem normalen alltag
[Musik]
überhaupt gut
schlafen einfach so mega abstruse
abtragen wir
[Musik]
er überlegt ob ihn eine reise in die
türkei die heimat seiner eltern aus der
depression reißen könnte
ein kuss hatte ihn eingeladen
wenn man das so unsicher im fall
getragen wir fast nichts buchen
maschine wird man wieder so einen schub
geben
die hessische merck oder windig ist es
für
nachhaltig sowie
die skis und riesa banken boni würde
klima des wohneigentums jeder
komfortzone sicherheit
schwierigen hat die momentane situation
ist völlig dass es eine normale
situation wird dass es ihm gut geht
außerdem sind wir es ist also sehr lange
symptom ist eigentlich gewöhnt aber es
ist gefährlich wenn sich autor und wird
sicherlich erst oder chronische zustand
das problem ist die gruppe national also
wenn also als freundeskreis oder vierter
oder fünfter bin wieder sehr schnell mit
und ist überfordert und dann
zurückziehen also wenn man zweimal ist
dann einfach noch im ausland auf der
couch und
das ist ja das ist vielleicht auch
geschwindigkeit einer sie zu machen und
man muss sehr flexibel sie und die tank-
oder hofft dass es
das ist oder dass es nicht zu lange auf
diese sind in die funde zum glück immer
mega hat immer zu mir kommt und von
haben unglaublich dankbar
[Musik]
ich habe schon viel gesprochen und es
verändert sich dann nicht so schnell so
viel und völlig
geschafft wo die musiker seine gedanken
und so oder so dass man nicht vom bett
liegt und dass es ständig kreist
[Musik]
josef hat hilfe von freunden und
therapeuten aber zu einer rückkehr ins
arbeitsleben fühlte sich noch nicht in
der lage
[Musik]
wer gegen psychische probleme kämpft
bleibt dem arbeitsleben viel länger fern
als bei fast allen anderen krankheiten
im durchschnitt dauert die
arbeitsunfähigkeit sechs monate
[Musik]
auch doris brülhart brauchte zeit sie
fand hilfe in der klinik hoheneck in
neuen und kehrt jetzt zurück um die
pflegefachfrau sven ihr ziel benndorf zu
besuchen die sie durch die schwere zeit
begleitet hat
sie wurde mir doch eine retten die in
labors true mehrfach schutz erhält frau
dann alles gemacht hätte vorher kaputt
gemacht hat ja so wenn irgendetwas sie
ist deponie zur aufgabe und sehe das wie
und wieso der räume drum gemacht
zehn wochen dauerte ihr aufenthalt in
der klinik
zum beispiel
hatten begann also wie setzen wir uns
danken am erdrücken droht gemacht
also fingen atem habe gemacht sie müsste
aber wer wirklich ganz heftig ist also
ja wie sieht erstmals an zwei heftige
situationen lag knapp entgangen und
svenja mir
in erinnerung und mit einem auto ist
jetzt mini
seine stark unter druck steht dass du
wirklich richtig weh und den haag
sieht mehr akrri möglichkeit mehr
anstehender 7 das geht aus einer stark
erhitzt dass einfach die ganze
aufmerksamkeit in der city dann schwarz
trainingssituation wahnsinnig hoch war
wir nennen es skills fertigkeiten
fähigkeiten um anspannung zu regulieren
und eben da gibt es so viele
möglichkeiten
da gilt es auch erstmal herauszufinden
was ich gerade schon gesagt was was bist
du für ein typ bist du jemand der was
riecht gerne bist du jemand der visuell
sehr stark ist der enns spüren kommt der
es übers über den geschmack sind zum
beispiel gut zugänglich ist also
versuchen den zugangs kanal natürlich
auch herauszufinden um zu spüren aber
sinnesreize da gibt es auch noch was
anderes außer das was jetzt gerade die
panik oder die anspannung auslöst
raus aus der situation das ist
eigentlich der sinn und zweck hinter
diesen skills raus aus der situation
dank verschiedener therapien kam doris
brühl hat im geschützten rahmen wieder
auf die beine
und doch bleibt ihr verhältnis zur
psychiatrie
zwiespältig
ich habe manchmal das gefühl gehabt die
hohenegg ist eigentlich eine wunderbare
institution des neo kapitalismus um die
leute dann wieder auf spur zu kriegen ja
damit sie hinterher wieder so voll von
den rubel rollen lassen genau genau das
eigentlich nur eine werkstatt ein
flickwerk stadt ja etwas ins system
reingehört
also es war das war wenn ich wieder mal
wieder wenn ich wieder mal so richtig
stinkesauer war auf dieses neoliberale
wirtschaftsplan in welchem ihr steckt
neoliberales wirtschafts gebaren was
läuft falsch in den unternehmen
es gab natürlich sehr viel ruhm für fox
die liegen jetzt reagieren normalfall
ist dass sie sehr sport wirklich auf der
mitarbeiter zu regeln oder gar nicht und
hilfiger erst
zeitpunkt nur schwer zu schlagen ist
nur ein paar wochen sind vergangen seit
er josef mit seinem freund marc überlegt
hat ob er verreisen seit wochen die
alles verändert haben
und
[Musik]
die wiederum ihr nicht und überhaupt in
pakistan zurückfinden
und das ist für mich mehr gefreut
mercator kekse
zwei wochen mit dem gus anton not wo
sehr viel natur hat sehr schöne natur
der aufenthalt hat sie ebenso wie so
viele gute energie gegen wir und aus
mehreren können wieso bist zu lasten von
mir nähe und wegspülen ich habe nie
wieder wieso
mit mit mit liebe und freude erfüllt
fühlt
die die stadt
glaubt wie möglich dass sie so eine ganz
andere perspektive räume wenn überall
das manko passiert ist oder und denn
überhaupt gefühl weil die hd tuner
familie und die studio zu mir und sind
die vermieter
dortmunder distanz zu ihnen hätten die
ganze zeit oder und da fühlt man sich
einfach mal wieso
ich heute entspannen und alle sachen
hand wie das für ihren vater mir oder
wohnung ist für das ist obgleich sterben
wir
[Musik]
auf dem weg zu einem termin bei der iv
beratung in ara
astrid peters ziel ist die
wiedereingliederung ihres klienten
35 coaching stunden stehen zur verfügung
kontakt war ich muss es gerade nutze und
und
jobs zu
meckern
völlig neuen sind einfacher gehts wohl
einfach so
und da habe ich sehr wohl interessieren
oder und noch hand von doch coach ich
muss mich bewerben oder eine chance
und etwa dass
das mit der klinik hat sagt ein
rückblick die eigene oder wohin sie sich
jetzt bevor hatte zuletzt 2 höhere
fachschule wunderbar also sie suchen
einfach aber beruflicher mathematik
dozent maximal acht lektionen pro woche
aber der selbst physik tönt wegen des
pensums realistisch konnte seine
vorfahren gesichertem eine strahlung für
die stück musik irgendwie mehr habe das
würde ich nicht so wichtig
es sind immer die frage nach den
speziellen stärken und schwächen sagt
sie denn ich sage ihm egal
[Musik]
bis also wie den früheren flamme das
erstarken
aber wenn das fest wird der drang news
von bergen werden muss man sich überlegt
wie wir effizient ich eigentlich energie
wo man dinge geht wie effizient wird das
überharte umgesetzt oder und ihm ist
wieso der richtige ansatzpunkt finden
oder
energie geht um wie viel
die beraterin empfiehlt er josef seine
psychischen probleme in den
bewerbungsgesprächen offen anzusprechen
er sage mir wenn schnell und nachhaltig
sie also besucher des treffs matching
besucher die stellen gut passt für der
kandidat wo er oder sie sich so wohl
fühle als umfeld finden wo solitäre
problematik vielleicht auch entspricht
oder mit der problematik an jugend wo
breites mit mantras schafe
[Musik]
stigma psychische krankheiten in einer
repräsentativen umfrage wünschen sich 90
prozent der arbeitgeberinnen und
arbeitgeber dass solche störungen im
vorstellungsgespräch angesprochen werden
aber nur 60 prozent der arbeitgeber
würden diese personen auch einstellen
[Musik]
es ist eigentlich völlig falsch dass
abschreibe wer zum beispiel führt
karriere zu machen wenn man sich mal
geteilt dass man probleme mit
alten ex etwas der pluspunkt sie will
entscheidend ist ja nicht über
irgendwelche probleme sondern mitunter
sonne
aktiv sind und und
[Musik]
verantwortungsvolles verhalten
in so einer situation und problematik
qualifiziert eigentlich für akw
world net bietet nicht nur abklärungen
und therapie sondern auch prävention
niklas bär mit einer kollegin auf dem
weg ins spital bethesda in basel
das publikum der veranstaltung
berufsbildner rinnen und berufsbildner
aus allen bereichen des spitals
niklas bär geht es um eine entkrampfung
im umgang mit psychischen beschwerden
und wir haben sehr gute partie auch
mit ihnen das thema für psychisch
auffällige lern und jetzt besprechen
internet zwei stunden so dass sie das
machen war es insgesamt finden sie am
schwierigsten wenn es um umgang mit
psychisch auffällig erlernen ich danke
schwierigste
im umgang mit dem lehrling dass das
problem überhaupt einmal ausspricht uni
im lehrling noch traten die türkei
diagnose wenn sie zu unserem ok betreue
ich mir stelle wo fälligkeit fest und
wir und ich die leute zu bewegen dass
sie vielleicht hilft also wir kamen
quasi die lehrer und überwege
unterstützung
sorgte lernt der fall nicht nur - puls
bilden und negativ sondern anteilig oder
im team und die fan muss ich sie
tricksen oder sagen dass ich alles in
ordnung und sich nur im rahmen bekommt
oder wie gegangen mit dem team gang
informieren
wenn die abschaltung
super junction firma nach klappte alle
zentrale thema heimat auf den reiter
die psychischen störungen und treten bei
der hälfte aller betroffenen zum ersten
mal in der jugend auf das heißt die
berufsbilder rinnen und berufsbildner
können wichtige weichen stellen wenn sie
die beschwerden rechtzeitig erkennen am
frisch derzeit psychische
auffälligkeiten im zwischenmenschlichen
kontakt der firma als bedächtig und
noch viel schöner aus die absenzen so
viele zwischenmenschliche spannungen
dort wird man sie erklimmen sie an
schnell wird man sie in reagieren was
ist früher stehen es gibt leute die sind
psychisch nicht krank und bringen auch
viel versucht damit sind sie sind
fröhlich lustig und twitter gratuliert
mit einer hummer kein problem da gibt es
leute die sind psychisch rang 14 sogar
schlager kommt aber sie bringen viel
ressource mit sie sind motiviert
verlässlich sie sind offen für lösungen
oder ich weiß nicht was dann kann man
sagen dass sie in lüthi machens beste
unsere schwierige situation und die wird
sagen dass sie nicht die lernenden was
ich die größte problem habe ich
verstanden
obwohl sie psychisch krank sind aber sie
bringen erhalt der hofer mit
umgekehrt geht schritte sind psychisch
nicht krank aber sie bringen nicht für
ihre soße es ist nicht so interessieren
sie sind nicht so freundlich nicht so
zuverlässig und er geht es wieder an
beides jana psychische krankheiten und
bringe nicht wieder so somit und das war
hat ein apple zum beispiel die zahl der
folge persönlichkeitsstörung
und wir würden ihnen nach dem fahrer
dass sie weniger loura was hätte man
psychisch kranken
sondern wir verhalten sich
und das ist mir egal das defizit bei
führungsverhalten und die fleischstücke
und
wird man wirklich sehr empfangen aber
sind diese finde was hätte ist der
borderline und
so weiter aber das verhalten und
gleichzeitig das definieren sie
ansprache
foto shooting im zürcher unterland
mit diesen bildern will doris brühl hat
ihre selbstproduzierten naturkosmetika
bewerben die sie in einer ersten phase
in einem workshop verkauft
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
der ausbruch der pandemie hat ihren elan
nicht gebremst
[Musik]
das geschäftslokal liegt am flughafen
zürich im neuen komplex the circle
es laufen die letzten
vorbereitungsarbeiten
hier soll eine wohlfühl oase entstehen
plus so der name des ladens heißt
glückseligkeit
im angebot hat sie massagen maniküre und
pediküre und natürlich die selbst
hergestellten kosmetikprodukte
allerdings zögert corona die eröffnung
immer weiter hinaus
[Musik]
anzieht
und das ist mit bucksteeg es ist
wirklich mit lustig
im geschäft steckt das eigene vermögen
und geld von verwandten wann zu den
ausgaben endlich einnahmen kommen ist
offen
das macht angst und unterdrückung
druck im brustkorb gespürt und das
gespür in
ironie
und das fühlt sich sehr anders als
früher ist das permanente taxi und sie
das sehr gesund gefühlt
ronny h
sie können mir besser und er hat
erfahren dass es
das maximal und die das mag sie alle
gehören und die probleme haben als
meister und
ich bin mir
da trifft ob er wusste viele minister
ohnmächtig und
verbaut als sie und macht gekommen
analysieren verbessern
und damit ein untergrund oder
autoritäre system hare grad was
passiert denn
die für bessere kenner
tourist brühl hat hat in der krise viel
gelernt über sich selbst
geduld braucht auch daniel seine
kündigung fiel auf den beginn der korona
epidemie seither schlägt er sich
notgedrungen die zeit um die ohren die
therapie bei world net ist beendet
die rose hannover messe züchtet zum teil
recht auf waren die das ist die seite
nicht die blumen tragen nicht als vier
stück davon nach entree bildet das
sogenannte gold rosi und
dabei 40 vorgang bis man überhaupt
einfach und
die jobsuche blieb bis heute erfolglos
jetzt fix sie richtig hat ein
mechanisches bild ich habe offenbar aus
glas
us apart gemacht allerdings nur
theoretische teil der beute schätzt er
nämlich langweilig dann wiederum mit
einer verschaffen und da sind dass du
die richtige allround oder aber was
natürlich ganz lässig war irgendwie es
offenbar vakuums beträgt meint
[Musik]
ich will einfach bis mache meint dass
eine formlose respektive steiles werden
ich will ich will noch besser
marken aufstößt
braucht viele
das ist schon eine sehr entscheidende
[Musik]
auch er 16 tage sind wieder lang und
leer von frau und kind lebt er getrennt
sein weg verläuft nicht gradlinig
vorstellungsgespräch
haltestelle haben also krimi pence im
plus für mich ist das sowieso vor allem
nach der trendlosen also wir keine
mathematik unterricht
auf einen
vergleichsweise höheren niveau
das ist bei mir nicht so gut gegangen in
berlin dezember
v6 über mini hat mini zwang
symptomatisch extrem starken ist so
stark wurde das ist jede nacht auf 520
dezember auf die triage verbracht haben
in der klinik also das klinikum ag und
die einfachen ach was haben wir die
listen im streit mit den zusagen die er
mich so fertigmachen
die zwangsstörung kennt er josef seite
jugend aber noch nie war sie so stark
wie jetzt
er muss sich immer wieder zwanghaft am
ganzen körper berühren
andauernder stress
das ist einfach
sehr oft derbe aufforderte gaben selber
von mir
zusammen rund und es ist ein gewisses
trotz oberschenkel es folgte ein
klinikaufenthalt der keine besserung
brachte die abklärungen zeigten dass er
seit langem an einer bipolaren störung
leidet er in the flies sich auch mehr
logisch untersuchen ohne ergebnis dank
einer ambulanten therapie kann er den
alltag einigermaßen bewältigen
[Musik]
verschiedene fall ist ein anderes wort
für die krise nach längerer schwieriger
situation wo es schwierig geworden ist
sich sehr viel komplexer als einfach nur
hauswirtschaft
[Musik]
seit ende des letzten jahres ist doris
brühl harz geschäft am flughafen endlich
offen
drei jahre nach ihrer großen krise
voller energie voller adrenalin voller
kraft voller freude voller dankbarkeit
eine menschenform ihr begleitet
unterstützt das ist toll
an den eröffnungstagen ist auch die
familie dabei
das sieht das alles geschafft hat das
ist wunderschön alles sich stimmig und
ich bin auch unglaublich beeindruckt
dass sie das alles alleine aufziehen
bis heute lässt sich doris brühl hat
therapeutisch begleiten
bernard ist viel mehr als eine
punktuelle krise schnelle lösungen für
die psychischen beschwerden gibt es
nicht
daniel eineinhalb jahre nach der
kündigung ist er immer noch auf
stellensuche
aus der persönlichen krise aber hat er
herausgefunden
sich aus wichtigsten überhaupt
unterstand das zählte dafür olli ist
formularen umfeld das wird
und dass man oft über kommen
ich denke das sind so die wichtigste
punkt das offen ist und ehrlich mit sich
selber vor allem
30 mal gegenüber und das modell 3ds und
seite ich hab ein problem und das wild
auslöser
und erika sf sein zusammenbruch liegt
mittlerweile zwei jahre zurück er wartet
auf einen platz in einem arbeitsprogramm
der iv und ist beim rav angemeldet
die einfach zur ruhe
irgendwie gemerkt das ist nicht einfach
zu mir wenn die
sie sind einfach nicht immer das
großartigste und interessante und weiß
eine was muss machen sondern dass sie
flüchtlinge einfach
es
viele moderne einfach es nochmals als
unspektakulär
routiniert blattes für das ist ein
polizist das ist einfach perfekt sie es
darf einfach wo es darf einfach easy
[Musik]